انا اتواجد الان في داخل مستشفى كمال
عدوان لنسلط الضوء على معاناه الجرحى
الذين اصيبوا خلال الحرب على غزه من قبل
قوات الاحتلال طبعا هنا تتفاقم معاناه
الجرحى يوما بعد يوم مع ازدياد واشتداد
هذه الحرب واشتداد الحصار عليهم ومنع
الاحتلال دخول الدواء ودخول العلاج هنا
الى شمال قطاع غزه المعاناه تتفاقم عند
هؤلاء جرحه وعند هؤلاء المرضى اغلب
الحالات الموجوده يعني هي حالات في وضع
صعب جدا وهناك مضاعفات كثيره نواجهها كل
يوم في هذه في هذا القسم وذلك لشح لشح
الامكانيات وشح الادويه المطلوبه يعني
بالاضافه الى انه هناك كثير من الحالات
التي تحتاج الى السفر بالخارج فيعني على
سبيل المثال هذا الطفل عنده كسر وعنده
هناك يعني نزيف راوي وموجود لديه بعض
الانابيب المزروعه في في في في الصدر
ويحتاج الى تدخل جراحي عاجل جدا هناك كسر
في العمود الفقري وهناك في شلل يعني هذه
الحالات لا يجوز ان ان نصبر عليها يعني
هذه الحالات يجب ان يتم ارسالها الى الى
اي بلد متقدم حتى ننقذ هذا هذا الطفل هناك
كثير من الجرحى اللي بيعانوا من طبعا من
تعفن في الجروح وبسبب قله اللي هي
الامكانيات العلاجيه للغيار وقله الادويه
الموجوده من مضدات الح
هذا بخلي
انه المريض ما يخرج بدرجه التحسن المطلوبه
يعني للعلم احنا المستشفى نحن ومستشفى
العوده الوحيدين اللي بنقدم الخدمه الصحيه
واغلب الحالات بالضبط يعني اغلب الحالات
تاتي من من غزه من مناطق غزه وشرق غزه
وغرب غزه يعني ومنطقه الشمال يعني هناك
كثير من الجلحه اللي فعلا محتاجين يعني
رعايه صحيه صحيحه قله الكواد الطبيه اللي
موجوده عندي الان وشح الامكانيات وقله
الادويه وقله المستهلكات هذا ففاق من
الوضع الصحي الموجود حالي في مستشفى كم
زبتي بقيت انا رايح بقيت رايح على الحمام
الا ايش بقف دقيقه الا بجيني طلق بالظهر
اللي ارتميت على الارض صرت ازحف لما وصلت
ظ وصلت يعني يوم من العصر لثاني يوم الصبح
لما
ص يعني وانا بنزف
اه لان مع شلل
برجلي ماقدرش امشي نفسي
امشي نفسي امشي واصير واطلع بره واتعالج
وامشي انا مش مش حاب اظني
هيك عندي مشاكل كثير بصدري
وبظهري عمود الفقار عندي مكسور كثير
وصدر كمان يعني مكسر اشياء يعني اذا هكذا
هو حال المرضى وحال الجرحى هنا في شمال
قطع غزه في ظل اشتداد هذه الحرب واشتداد
الحصار ومنع الاحتلال دخول الدواء ومنع
الاحتلال السماح بالسفر لهؤلاء المرضى
وهؤلاء الجرحى لتلقي العلاج خارج قطاع غزه
انس الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه